reconnaître ces filles je ne les ai pas
vues puis-je m'asseoir qu'est-ce que tu fais le camping-car
c'est ma question il dort là tu
dors là-dedans tu dormais là-
bas l'autre jour pourquoi le camping-car était-il
garé devant la maison mm-hmm est allé pour
un trajet en voiture il est allé faire un trajet en voiture vous ne
conduisiez pas je sais que ces filles
jouaient à l'extérieur de votre camping-car vous ne
conduisiez pas son garé était-ce surtout
qu'ils prévoyaient d'emmener des gens les filles
oh il l'a fait avant non n'as-tu pas demandé  lui
pour coïncider oh oui je sors du
camping-car et ensuite tu l'emmènes non tu as
mis ces filles quelque part oui tu as
mis ces filles comme en contact je sais que
tu as mis ces filles lui